take a look out your window put on your
glasses if you wear them you might want
to grab a pair of binoculars too or a
magnifying lens now what do you see well
whatever it is it's not the multiple
layers of glass right in front of you
but have you ever wondered how something
so solid can be so invisible
to understand that we have to understand
what glass actually is and where it
comes from it all begins in the earth's
crust where the two most common elements
are silicon and oxygen these react
together to form silicon dioxide whose
molecules arrange themselves into a
regular crystalline form known as quartz
quartz is commonly found in sand where
it often makes up most of the grains and
is the main ingredient in most types of
glass of course you've probably noticed
that glass isn't made of multiple tiny
bits of quartz and for good reason for
one thing the edges of the rigidly
formed grains and smaller defects within
the crystal structure reflect and
disperse light that hits them but when
the quartz is heated high enough the
extra energy makes the molecules vibrate
until they break the bonds holding them
together and become a flowing liquid the
same way that ice melts into water
unlike water though liquid silicon
dioxide does not reform into a crystal
solid when it cools instead as the
molecules lose energy they are less and
less able to move into an ordered
position and the result is what is
called an amorphous solid a solid
material with the chaotic structure of a
liquid which allows the molecules to
freely fill in any gaps
this makes the surface of glass uniform
on a microscopic level allowing light to
strike it without being scattered in
different directions
but this still doesn't explain why light
is able to pass through glass rather
than being absorbed as with most solids
for that we need to go all the way down
to the subatomic level
you may know that an atom consists of a
nucleus with electrons orbiting around
it but you may be surprised to know that
it's mostly empty space in fact if an
atom were the size of a sports stadium
the nucleus would be like a single pea
in the center while the electrons would
be like grains of sand in the outer
seats
that should leave plenty of space for
light to pass through without hitting
any of these particles so the real
question is not why is glass transparent
but why aren't all materials transparent
the answer has to do with the different
energy levels that electrons in an atom
can have
think of these as different rows of
seats in the stadium stands an electron
is initially assigned to sit in a
certain row but it could jump to a
better row if it only had the energy
as luck would have it absorbing one of
those light photons passing through the
atom can provide just the energy the
electron needs but there's a catch
the energy from the photon has to be the
right amount to get an electron to the
next row otherwise it will just let the
photon pass by and it just so happens
that in glass
the rows are so far apart that a photon
of visible light can't provide enough
energy for an electron to jump between
them
photons from ultraviolet light on the
other hand give just the right amount of
energy and are absorbed which is why you
can't get a suntan through glass
this amazing property of being both
solid and transparent has given glass
many uses throughout the centuries from
windows that let in light while keeping
out the elements to lenses that allow us
to see both the vast worlds beyond our
planet and the tiny ones right around us
it is hard to imagine modern
civilization without glass
and yet for such an important material
we rarely think about glass and its
impact it is precisely because the most
important and useful quality of glass is
being featureless and invisible that we
often forget it's even there
you